while the Kremlin has broadcast a video
showing President Vladimir Putin
visiting two Army posts in
russian-controlled areas of Ukraine the
footage was broadcast on state
television showing Putin speaking to
military leaders about the combat
situation in southern herzan Moscow says
he was then flown by a helicopter to
Eastern lugansk to hear reports from
commanders there we'll bring in dorsa
Jabari she's joining us for Moscow so
the trip is the second visit by Putin to
Russian occupied areas in Ukraine in as
many months dorsa what is the message
that's being sent out
well first Doreen this is the first time
that we've seen the commander-in-chief
of the Russian Armed Forces paying a
visit in person to the Troops the visit
he had last month was to Residents in
the city of mariopol and he took that
trip in the cover of Darkness where he
drove himself in and around that City
and made surprise visits to ordinary
citizens there but this is a very
different one clearly conveying a
message of someone who is very sure of
himself and very much in command of the
situation of his troops in Ukraine as
well as trying to boost morale of the
Russian army that is currently fighting
in Ukraine we saw the 70 year old
Vladimir Putin coming down from a
helicopter in Herson region where he met
commanders there and he said that he's
there to listen to them and to exchange
ideas he then later moved on to visit
the headquarters of the national guards
in the lugan's region that is in donbass
and there he presents
officials there with a gold triptych and
he said this was a present for Easter
which people here celebrated on Sunday
the Orthodox Easter and he said that
this triptych once belonged to one of
the greatest Russian defense ministers
in the country's Empire clearly a
message to boost morale and also to show
strength and that he currently still
believes that this war that he's
launched can be Won Won by his troops
okay dorsa thank you Teresa Jabari
reporting from Moscow